- Teachers are the single
most important actor
in students' learning.
Hi, I'm Sal Khan, Founder of
the not-for-profit organization
Khan Academy.
And I just want to tell
all you teachers out there
that we have an exciting
program for this summer.
It's called Khan Academy Teacher Training.
And we want to do everything that we can
to ensure that you have the content,
the software, the tools, and the training
to best meet the needs of your student.
And so Khan Academy Teacher Training
is a learning program that'll
take you about an hour
that allow you to learn
from other teachers
who are successfully using Khan Academy
and seeing gains in their classroom.
You'll get guides on how to
use it in your classroom,
and we'll also encourage
you to have a plan
for how you might want to implement it.
If you complete this roughly one hour,
you'll get a certificate and a chance
to come visit us so that we can learn more
from each other.
So I encourage you to
participate this summer.
I think together we can
really make a big difference
for learners everywhere.
(upbeat instrumental music)